Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite --
"My Weird Superstition"
stories from you guys.
Here we go. This first one's
from @JesseBetts11.
He says,
"Whenever I'm home alone,
I always say, 'I see you'
before falling asleep just
to see if anyone responds."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Okay, okay.
Then I'll leave then.
You can see me?
I thought I was hiding but --"
-Yeah.
-"All right."
This one's from @hasasimo.
He says, "My brother-in-law
doesn't allow his mother
into the room if
the Dallas Cowboys are winning.
If she's already in the room,
he doesn't let her leave.
He's done this
for over 20 years.
The cowboys haven't been to
a Super Bowl in over 20 years."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, leave your mom alone!
-It's his fault.
-Yeah.
This one's from @NicolaFry1980.
She says,
"When I take painkillers,
I have to whisper
what's wrong with me first
like 'headache'
or 'sore shoulder,'
or else the medicine
won't know where to go."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Sore shoulder."
Mnh.
-I like that one.
-This one's from
@RunningUnicorns.
-Ohh.
How quaint.
-She says,
"I never eat the first Pringle
in a can, that's
the barrier Pringle.
I throw it away every time."
[ Laughter and applause ]
What? Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, no.
-"No, no, no,
that's the barrier Pringle.
Unh-unh. Nice try!"
-That's got factory germs on it.
-"Nice try.
I don't want anything
to do with that one."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @timeofbacon.
-Time of bacon.
-Yeah.
He says, "Any time someone on
TV winks, I have to wink back."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Audience cheering ]
"I see you!"
"Who?!"
-This one's from @motownphyllie.
She says -- This is great.
-What'd she say?
-"When I was little, my mom
told me that every grain
of rice I didn't finish
in my dinner bowl
would be a zit
on my future husband's face."
[ Audience "ohhs", laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
What?! Oh, my goodness.
Wow.
-Oh.
-This one's from
@DarolineCavrnas.
She says, "I had a bad case
of the hiccups,
and they finally went away when
I talked about Sandra Bullock.
Now my brother and I will
discuss Sandra Bullock
when one of us have hiccups
and they always go away."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Really? That's the secret?
Stare at a spoon and just think
of Sandra Bullock.
-Yeah, Bandra Sullock.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Hiccups ]
You just gave my hiccups.
-Yeah, I gave you the hiccups.
[ Laughter ]
-This last one's
from @rtran1251.
You think that's a robot?
-I hope so.
-She says, "I halfway
believe in aliens,
but I try my hardest not
to think about them
because if they're real,
they for sure read minds
and then they'd know
that I know that they know."
Oh. Okay.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it, those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
Go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.